[Music]  we have a few questions where were you  the night Lily bridges disappeared  Lucy this is Lilly Lilly Lucy fly so how  long have you been in Japan three weeks  now too weird no everyone stares at you  it's like being famous  some people get addicted to those you  and that normal either you know so let's  not pretend to be you photograph  everything of course  do you have a boyfriend thank you he's  so cute cute Ohio he's gorgeous he's  like obsessed with you  why do you say huh I know man she's a  piece of work that one  it's like you'd only one who exists then  she moves on to someone else it's like  you were never even there do you see a  better future come on  we have something no one else could  share  don't turn about I do  sitting around I know what I'm feeling  and it's not right at all  you must trust  Oh  like something really bad is going to  happen  [Music]